algunas veces las definiciones pueden
ser un poco confusas por lo que quería
repasar los términos región selectividad
estéreo selectividad y estéreo
especificidad ahora para hacer esto
vamos a utilizar los ejemplos que hemos
visto en los últimos vídeos si quieres
conocer todos los detalles de estas
reacciones regresa a vídeos anteriores
vamos a empezar con la región
selectividad tenemos aquí una reacción
que es región selectiva este alcohol
sufre un proceso de deshidratación y
obtenemos estos dos productos ahora
estos dos al que nos son región isómeros
lo escribimos por acá regio isómeros así
es que estos dos al que nos son isómeros
pero su doble enlace se encuentra en
lugares distintos él y somero de la
izquierda tiene su doble enlace por acá
y el y somero de la derecha su doble
enlace se encuentra por acá ahora
esta es una reacción región selectiva
por lo que uno de estos región isómeros
es favorecido producimos más de uno de
estos isómeros que del otro en el caso
específico de esta reacción el al que no
trees sustituido es el mayoritario
producimos una mayor cantidad de este al
que no mientras que este otro al que no
esté al que no de sustituido es el
producto minoritario producimos una
menor cantidad de este regio y somero
bueno ahora vamos a ver la exterior
selectividad por aquí tenemos un alcohol
que también sufre una deshidratación al
reaccionar con el ácido sulfúrico y como
producto nos da estos dos ar que nos
pero veamos el mecanismo de reacción
primero protón amos el grupo hidroxilo
para que sea una molécula de agua porque
las moléculas de agua si son buenos
grupos salientes y entonces esa molécula
de agua se va produciendo un kart
vocación
en carga formal positiva vamos a
dibujarlo por acá aquí tenemos nuestro
carbó catión bencílico que tiene una
carga formal positiva y entonces este
kart vocación tiene dos posibilidades
puede tomar cualquiera de los dos
protones de este carbono y dependiendo
de cuál de estos dos protones toma ese
carbó catión se forma alguno de estos
productos este de acá es el producto
trans y este es el producto cis ahora
estos dos isómeros son estéreo isómeros
vamos a escribirlo por acá estéreo
isómeros esta reacción es estéreo
selectiva eso significa que uno de estos
dos estéreo isómeros es favorecido por
encima del otro
en este caso el producto trans es el
favorecido es el producto mayoritario
porque es el más estable así es que
obtenemos más productos trans
y el al que nos cis es el minoritario y
ahora vamos a ver exterior especificidad
en una reacción estéreo especifica la
estéreo química del sustrato determina
la estéreo química del producto y una
reacción de eliminación de dos es un muy
buen ejemplo de una reacción estéreo
específica aquí a la izquierda tenemos
dos moléculas muy parecidas tenemos dos
grupos en hilos un átomo de bromo pero
es muy importante observar la estéreo
química de este carbono tenemos un grupo
metilo saliendo hacia nosotros y un
hidrógeno alejándose de nosotros cuando
nuestra base fuerte se lleva a éste
protón obtenemos un y al que no así es
que aquí tenemos estéreo química en este
producto esto nos dice que los grupos en
hilos están en lados opuestos del doble
enlace pero ahora podemos observar esta
otra reacción con esta molécula que es
muy parecida
dos grupos venidos pero la estéreo
química en este carbono cambio la única
diferencia entre estas dos moléculas es
la estéreo química en ese carbono aquí
tenemos un átomo de hidrógeno
acercándose hacia nosotros y un grupo
metilo que se está alejando en la
reacción nuestra base fuerte llega y se
lleva a este protón el protón beta pero
esta vez obtenemos un zeta al que no
entonces la estéreo química del sustrato
determina la estéreo química del
producto este mecanismo no te da
distintas opciones
simplemente determina cuál y somero se
produce si en algún momento vemos alguno
de estos productos por ejemplo si vemos
el producto zeta
sabemos inmediatamente cuál es la
estéreo química de este carbono tiene
que tener exactamente está estéreo
química para que el producto sea el
cetal que no y lo mismo sucede con esta
reacción si tenemos un
al que no entonces sabemos
inmediatamente
cuál es la estéreo química de este
carbono así es que la información de la
estéreo química del sustrato se mantiene
en las reacciones estéreo específicas
bueno ahora vamos a comparar dos
términos que se parecen mucho estéreo
selectividad con estéreo especificidad
como acabamos de ver hace unos cuantos
segundos una reacción es estéreo
especifica si la estéreo química del
sustrato determina la estéreo química
del producto toda la información estéreo
química es preservada por el mecanismo
de esta reacción y eso es distinto a lo
que sucede con las reacciones estéreo
selectivas si nos fijamos por acá la
estéreo química de este grupo o h
no es preservada en esta reacción se
pierde cuando formamos este car vocación
por ejemplo pudimos haber empezado con
este grupo o h con una línea punteada en
lugar de una cuña
y hubiéramos obtenido exactamente el
mismo resultado entonces la información
estéreo química del sustrato no es
preservada bueno vamos a regresar un
poco si tenemos una reacción estéreo
específica y nuestro producto es un y al
que no entonces conocemos exactamente la
estéreo química del sustrato porque es
una reacción estéreo específica pero si
el lugar tenemos una reacción estéreo
selectiva si tenemos por ejemplo este
producto trans o este producto cis esto
no nos dice nada acerca de la histeria
química del sustrato no sabemos cuál es
la estéreo química de este carbono no
nos dice si el grupo o h
se encuentra con unas líneas punteadas o
si se encuentra con una cuña así es que
esta no es una reacción estéreo
específica puedes pensar en una reacción
estéreo selectiva como que simplemente
selecciona al producto trans
independientemente de la estéreo química
del sustrato